our first speaker is vara Wexler mara is
professor of American studies professor
of women's gender and sexuality studies
professor of film and Media Studies at
Yale University she's a busy person
professor Wexler is co-director of Yale
public humanities founding director of
Yale photographic memory workshop a
member of the steering committee of the
feminist technology network and
principal investigator of the photo
grammar project she has served a care of
the women's gender and sexuality studies
program and co-chair of the Yale women's
faculty forum professor Wexler has an
undergraduate degree from Sara Lance
college and ma MPhil and PhD degrees
from Columbia University welcome
professor web thank you the organizers
for inviting me so all right
okay okay so in the summer of nineteen
thirty-five economists rexford tugwell
who is a former Columbia University
professor of economics and the current
head of the Roosevelt administration's
resettlement administration created an
information division for his agency and
he appointed to that information
division another younger University
Columbia University economist Roy
Stryker to lead its historical section
that was going to be a public relations
unit the need was dire the resettlement
administration had replaced the
Agricultural Adjustment administration
after the former agency had created an
unforeseen crisis on top of the already
critical situation of American
agriculture in the depression by paying
farmers to reduce agricultural
production the earlier government agency
had successfully raised commodity prices
which was its goal but simultaneously it
started pushing small farmers and
sharecroppers out of their livelihood
which was its unintended consequence
family farms were being hit by a triple
whammy modernization brought large-scale
industrial farming with which it was
difficult to compete loss of American
market share to European farms that were
now recovering from the devastation of
World War one brought further
competition an extensive and extended
drought combined with inexpert land
management brought the ecological
emergency of the Dust Bowl hundreds of
thousands of formerly independent farm
families were being rapidly thrown into
the migrant transitory labor market the
resettlement agency like other New Deal
agencies was set up to mitigate the
damage and Roosevelt's enemies in
Congress were poised to stop it the main
job of the historical division of the
resettlement administration therefore
was to practice a public relations
policy that would be as potent as
possible the task was bureaucratic they
were to supply media with photographs
that showed the success of the
government's programs striker hired an
extraordinary group of photographers
including Dorothea Lange Walker Evans
Gordon Parks and
sent amount and field assignments to do
this work they would work basically on
the job she scripted but in the
interstices he promised they would be
able to take a day here a day there
that's part of why they signed up for
the government job because you could do
that to explore a material that
particularly interested them this is
where as you later would put it they
conspired with him to get what history
has proved to be the guts of the project
ultimately the greatest success of the
historical division of the resettlement
administration accomplished its goals of
introducing Americans to Americans but
not only during the Great Depression but
also long after in fact when we in the
21st century want to look back and see
who we once were in order to picture and
assess who we are now becoming it is
very often to the FSA photographic
archive that we turn the FSA photographs
represent the largest indeed the only
large-scale government-sponsored
documentary project in united states
history the nearly 170,000 surviving
photographs of the more than 250,000 an
agency produced in the ten years between
nineteen thirty-five and 1945 resided
the Library of Congress were access to
them as public and rights of
reproduction are essentially free they
are also available for search and
download on the Library of Congress
website they are widely recognized as
one of the treasures of the American
people arguably the FSA photographers
were more successful than the agencies
they were created to support the
baseline idea was to improve the lives
of marginal farmers by purchasing
submarginal land and recloaking
individual and often isolated families
to better land on group farms where
economies could be more efficient than
scientific expertise could be learned
shared and consolidated aggressively
attacked by congressional critics as
collectivized our agriculture the movers
and shakers of the resettlement
administration were very often on a
defensive their budgets repeatedly
slashed instead of success in Todd wells
original goal of moving 650,000 people
sustainably on to 100 million acres of
what was becoming of new Lane
and they were only able to move a few
thousand people on 29 million acres
instead they were forced to build about
75 relief camps in California were about
seven hundred seventy five thousand
destitute migrants who were entirely on
almost entirely unwelcome in the state
were temporarily housed in clean
quarters with running water they also
built a few Greenbelt model cities for a
future that never came in 1936 facing
widespread criticism rexall dug word
rexford tugwell resigned and in 1937 the
resettlement administration was
transferred to the Department of
Agriculture and the Farm Security Act
transformed it into the Farm Security
Administration one can and many have and
do argue the relative value of the
farming programs one particularly
stinging criticism concerns the basic
structural and also actively overt
racism that underlay the project often
creating disparities in who was
portrayed as the deserving poor whose
histories on the land were envisioned
and respected and whose were erased and
who received relief key FSA programs
removed former tenants and replace them
with FSA clients throughout the
Mississippi Delta both black and white
but racial segregation was accepted
black clients at the time were unable to
challenge such policies but it has also
been argued that the agency itself
created the ideological and practical
infrastructure through which the black
farmers would eventually challenge the
white supremacy of resettlement this
documentary project however the
photographic project is generally
considered to be an astounding success
if the more than 170,000 extant and
widely beloved photographs contain
exculpatory or contradictory evidence
about the intentions and effects of New
Deal policies it is very difficult
however to turn it up the FSA archive is
a very large very messy data set inter
photo grammar a digital research tool
supported by the NIH and the ACLS and
developed at Yale by the phonogram
irking the team consists of two
co-directors former yale graduate
students taylor arnold in statistics and
Lauren Tilton in American Studies and
they're both
now at the University of Richmond Stacy
maples former GIS librarian at Yale and
now at the david rumsey map Center at
Stanford University Kenneth panko former
yell technologist now at Yale and us
Peter Leonard yells first digital
humanities librarian and head of the D H
lab in Sterling Memorial Library
Kirkpatrick technologist and yells
teaching and learning laboratory and
myself after six years profoundly a
digitally who monste a digitally human
enhanced humanist I am the principal
investigator of the photograph one
intervention that we immediately made
and and was to was to create a group a
web-based many-layered interactive
geospatial map to render this archive
fluently searchable and you see the you
see in this slide the mapping that
resulted and when we did this absolutely
immediately we overturned the first sort
of stereotypical truism that scholars
have since the 1930s been repeating
about this project which is that it is
about Appalachia and the Dust Bowl the
minute that you map the photograph what
you find is that it's a project of
national scope and that it covers not
only you know from Maine to Florida
there's even sites offshore but also in
the old industrial cities as well as the
as well as the heartland and the
farmland of the country and why this is
and why it keeps getting repeated that
really it's about a palaca and the Okies
moving west to California is something
that I believe that mapping and studying
the FSA archive as a big messy data set
will eventually allow us to learn about
so let me just give you a kind of a
quick torrents light of the website you
will recognize many of these photographs
they are not only our cultural heritage
but our cultural imaginary of who we
were during the
great great depression these are Walker
Evans's photographs of the sharecroppers
in that were published in the book let
us now praise famous men that he
co-authored with James Agee this is the
office of the the women actually in the
back offices who were categorizing and
tagging the hundreds of thousands of
photographs as they came in under the
auspices of a brilliant librarian named
Paul Vanderbilt this was Vanderbilt's
first effort at tagging actually
creating categories for visual
categories for photographs he went on to
head the Wisconsin Historical Society
into incredible work there but these
these are the labor force behind what
Vanderbilt was doing who and they are
anonymous the FSA files exist in red
file cabinet in the library of congress
now as analog objects material objects
and they also exist online in the
library of congress website but both of
these are very very difficult to search
in 2001 i was part of a small group of
scholars brought to the library of
congress to search physically through
these drawers and find find interesting
information about the FSA photographs
that we didn't already know and out of
that I think probably eight or nine of
us very little new interesting
information resulted from that because
you in even in a week of looking it's
too unwieldy it's too difficult there
are too many factors there's too much
information to search that way this is
one of the reasons that the photo
grammar project got started so here's a
dozen the map in and we we also made we
also took ten of the I think it's time
primary
most famous most well-known
photographers and ism colors and trace
tracked their trail across the country
and we interleaved this with a 1937
highway map so because if you're looking
for sort of mystified or occluded
political choices in where the FSA was
doing its work one of the ways to sort
of try to figure that out is to see
whether the people doing fieldwork were
following the main transportation routes
were going on the back roads were
relating to minority communities or not
and it's the road map that can tell you
that we also discovered this the the
blue dots that we first thought were
route 66 going west it's actually a
trained it's not route 66 at all okay so
okay so yeah so that's the trip going
west we really threaded the needle in
terms of a digital humanities project
with the photogrammetry cause this is
open access open data that's owned by
the people of the United States and so
we were able with the tremendous
tremendous wonderful willing cooperation
of the Library of Congress we were
willing to we were able to work with the
beautifully digitized photographs that
they twice did in two different
generations of digital capacity and put
online and with metadata that they also
as wonderful librarians kept attached
this is public open information when we
presented this project in other fora
other other peep utter groups of people
have said well could we do could we do
photogram Ron are the u.s. Holocaust
Memorial Museum wanted to do a
photographic eynde of a mass
with letters and photographs and
information that people were sending
them but it turns out that it's a
present there are restrictions on that
information it's a proprietary archive
it can't it can't it there-there's again
and again and again people contact us we
say all of our coding all of our
information is on gut github it's all
free for you talk to us we're happy to
help you and they cannot do this work
because they what would you want to call
it foresight or happenchance or whatever
it is of the government in 1936 made
this public archive ok so the all right
and so you see you see something we've
circled here on the attached metadata
called lot number and that has to do
with the original coding system that
Vanderbilt in that room of workers was
doing and we also coordinated we got
ahold of Vanderbilt's key handbook and
we coordinated his categories with these
photographs so that we can see how he
and the government and the general media
were thinking of this portrait of
Americans at the time one of the
categories we actually love is people as
such without emphasis on their activity
that is actually one of his categories
people as such I think this may be one
of the people as such but what you see
is that actually you also have you have
because these photographs are publicly
owned scholars of the United States have
gone to this archive to get images for
their books and articles without much
expense and without you can always get
permission and what that means is
there's been a kind of I don't know what
a scientists are called but a high
replication effect of a limited number
of of photographs and so we actually
only know
small amount of what the images are in
this archive in every single time i open
up photograph i find new images okay we
one of the innovations of photogravure
okay so what striker and the team we're
doing in the 1930s was turning data into
images the government had data were the
agencies working and he was turning it
into images so that Americans could see
and understand who one another are what
we have done with those images is to
turn them back into data which gives us
now another way of searching combining
inquiring and understanding the nature
of this photographic system and how it
applies to our political past and our
current situation this is Vanderbilt
this is a tree map we made of vanderbilt
1942 classification system you can see
people as much you go you drill down in
it into it in in three segments and you
see you see what they're looking for
horse shows circus dance orchestra is
group singing this is the way they are
thinking of a portrait of the country is
it our portrait of the country know
what's interesting is the difference
between that portrait of the country and
our portrait of the country okay i want
to just I'm going to go very quickly
through and hope to show you one more
thing their color ones hardly anybody
knew that we have been using facial
recognition to kind of categorize the
photographs this is not very
theoretically well substantiated we are
looking for kind of I don't know
morphological features and trying to see
what kind of we're just experimenting
with the images and trying to see what
kind of what kind of pictures we get and
can we actually find more
african-americans visible
african-americans this way and then
finally I want to show you tell you a
story that that would never have
happened yes it wasn't a group this kind
of a group this kind of a totally
interdisciplinary cross-disciplinary
group with technologists digital human
and these librarian me I'm a historian
of photography someone who had worked in
museums a statistician a GIS expert this
is our team we were in Washington and
talking to the Beverly bannon who's the
chief curator of this archive we're
around the table and Taylor Arnold the
statistics graduate student at the TT he
finished his PhD but at the time we're
sitting in a corner needs looking at
since this number this number call
number la la la la dash m4 and he says
what does that mean I'm for and the
librarian says we I don't we all know we
don't know but best practices are to
keep the keep the mark record keep the
metadata intact so in all these years
the librarians and Congress did that
what is this M number and what what
after thinking about it for a long time
Taylor and Lauren figured out is that M
number okay the M number has to do with
this the government photographers were
supplied by government supplies and it
was cheaper to give them large
industrial roll film then film that
those who didn't even remember film will
remember which used to come in 24 and 36
exposure rolls so they had large rolls
and they were constrained to go out in
the field and shoot pictures and send
the rolls of film back home back to
Washington where a lab developed and
printed them and then you know there's a
process of choosing so the lab Doug did
this and it caught the rolls of film
into about 6 or 8 inch eight six or
eight frame segments when they were done
I throw the segments into a metaphorical
pot they were not interested in keeping
the segment's aggregated they're looking
for individual images to substantiate
reports and government documents
so they threw these ok so what Taylor
figured out is that the M number had to
do with which frame it is on the
negative strip and when he was able to
write a program that could reunify the
negative stretch so here's an example
John VaShawn in july of 1941 he's in
wisconsin and he's photographing cheese
jeez jeez jeez jeez do anything cute
right then there's a blank there's a
there's a blank frame and Max laying
frame represents actually his crossing
the next frame is to Chicago where the
next picture is that as a down-and-out
man sinning I guess it's on a fire
hydrant and then the Turing of thought
the shooting goes to photographing that
man now it's absolutely extraordinary
we've been able to reunify a certain
number of these and we now have a grant
Taylor and Lauren are working on this
enrichment to reunify many many more but
what you have here or now the historian
is this question why is the jump from
stop cheese than you configure i'm tired
of cheese to this man in chicago and the
question for a depression historian the
question there ride is here is that John
is John Besh alone thinking we make so
much cheese in this country Wisconsin is
not very far from Chicago what is the
reason we cannot get the cheese to the
people who are hungry jeez now comes in
aid baskets and I kind of wonder whether
this is the kind of prehistory of that
but the question is a question that goes
to the heart of the New Deal do we need
a different kind of this production and
distribution system in order to get what
is needed to the people who need it
[Music]
that's the question so all right so Roy
strikers brilliant photographers
transform data into photograph I've said
that the brilliant photogram our team
has transformed these photographs back
into data the enduring question is from
a digitally enhanced humanist point of
view cui bono who benefits from this
knowledge and how thank
[Applause]